Marc Olivier qui vous demande pourquoi
vous fuyez le bonheur vous dites pour ne
pas dépasser mon père pour le laisser là
où il est en
haut nous allons recevoir Guillaume de
pardieu et Marc Olivier Fogel qu'on ne
présente plus ni l'un ni l'autre qui se
sont rencontrés sur les plateaux de
télévision et qui ont décidé d'écrire
d'écrire ensemble un livre sur la vie
tourmentée pour le moins de Guillaume de
pardu donc on les reçoit hein juste
après le reportage en images qui retrace
les entretiens qu'ils ont sur les
plateaux de Marc Olivier Fogel tout au
long de ces 6 années j'en ai rien à
de ce qu'on pense de moi et puis
il y a pas besoin de G d'ailleurs pour
que les journalistes soi des nuls entre
l'enfant terrible du cinéma et celui de
la télévision la rencontre était
inévitable le premier face à face
Guillaume de pardieu Marc Olivier fael a
lieu en
1997 tout à l'heure avant de commencer
l'interview je demandais si ça allait
Guillaume et vous me disiez jamais sur
un plateau de télévision ou c'est pas du
tout mon élément non parce que je trouve
que voilà
je pensais à cette expression m'a
reproché de de pas jouer le jeu jouer le
jeu mais quel jeu plusou pour quelqu'un
qui n'aime pas les plateaux télé
Guillaume de par Dieu se prête plutôt
bien au jeux de Marc Olivier faogiel et
répond présent à chacune de ses
invitations on reçit dans un instant
Guillaume de pardieu Guillaume de
pardieu qui construit une nouvelle vie
après des débuts difficiles et
chaotiqu rendez-vous est pris à chaque
fois que l'artiste tourmenté a envie de
parler tous les thèmes sont abordé au
fil des entretiens Marc Olivier dévoile
la vie agitée de Guillaume qui se livre
sans tabou
donner la vie c'est forcément y croire à
la vie c'est pour ça c'est ce que je je
vous disais tout à l'heure ça y est là
vous y croyez à la vie ouai bien sûr j'y
crois
ou
ouais a ton père est sorti aussi et moi
j'étais assez frappé de la façon dont
vous balanciez encore à nouveau sur vos
rapports avec votre père et en plus non
c'était pour rire ça c'est un joke
comment c'était pour un joke qui dure 4
ans oui donc faut vraiment être fé pour
faire ça ouais il faut être vachement fé
mais pourquoi est-ce que si vous avez
besoin et pourquoi pas c'est votre façon
de passer par la presse pour lui dire
des choses que vous n'arrivez pas à lui
dire parce que c'est votre relation avec
lui jamais eu besoin de la presse pour
dire des choses à mon père je va te
faire quand j'avais déjà 6 ans et
demi tu as décidé de médiatiser ce qui
t'arrive la maladie que tu as contracté
à l'hôpital ce qu'on appelle les
maladies les infections
nosocomiales qui vont faire que tu vas
devoir subir une
amputation je veux dire je suis condamné
à me changer de vie à 30 ans quoi a
marque que ma fille me voit comme ça
donc j'aime pas qu'on me vienne ça ouais
ouais et tu as dit que jusqu'à ce
qu'elle soit grande je je me dois d'être
là ça veut dire que c'est elle qui te
tient en vie quoi gros modo la vie de
Guillaume est un roman et quand un
éditeur lui demande d'en faire un livre
c'est tout naturellement à Marc Olivier
qu'il fait
appel ça c'est fait comme ça tout
naturellement et c'est vraiment une une
amitié qui est née entre vous moi c'est
plus une confiance en tout cas moi c'est
vrai queà chaque fois qu' qu' m'appelle
pour me parler de quelque chose c'est
d'abord qu'il a réfléchi à pourquoi à ma
présence et puis donc en plus c'est lui
qui appelle pour que vous parliez oui il
va il va se confier en vous appelant
jeésente quand vous dites Guillaume il
m'appelle pour me parler de quelque
chose mais il a une oreil attentif
Guillaume he il est ouaisouis c'est pas
simplement quelqu'un qu'on sollicite
pour raconter des choses on se conf vous
échangez vraiment des choses ouou bien
sûr et vous aviez envie vraiment de de
tout la seule personne en fait hein
c'est ça c'est la seule personne qui qui
de qui je pouvais entendre ces questions
là c'est sans sans lui je pense que
jeurais même moi tout seul j'aurais pas
pu le faire objectivement c'est une
façon d'avancer aussi Guillaume il aime
la vérité et et il se fait pas de cadeau
donc dans les questions et dans ce que
je lui a renvoyé de lui-même c'était pas
du tout un accouchement facile d'une
certaine manière et je l'ai jamais pris
à défaut de mensonge ou de de tricherie
il est il est vrai quoi et donc moi
j'aime cette vérité là et donc voilà on
a une relation vraie en fait est-ce que
c'était une une façon de de faire le
point sur votre vie et comme vous l'avez
dit de de tourner la la la page sur le
passé est-ce que c'est la fin et plus
jamais vous ne parlerez de votre père de
la drogue la prostitution tout ce qui
vous est arriv certain manière oui oui
bien sûr ou maintenant moi j'ai balayé
il me semble à peu près tout tout tout
ce qui faisait ce qui avait fait ce qui
m'a construit d'une certaine manière ce
qui a fait ce que je suis aujourd'hui
donc sans le renier sans le le porter au
nu sans l'encenser mais en tout cas avec
honnêteté le plus possible et pour
pouvoir justement passer à autre chose
et voilà je c'est c'est c'est une
transition ouais vous êtes sûr qu'on on
tourne une page pour passer à autre
chose finalement on y revient souvent en
tout cas moi je l'ai tourné donc est
tourné qu'est-ce qui vous a construit
vous Guillaume qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous diriez parce que tout le monde
tout autour de de cette table avant que
vous n'arriviez l'un et l'autre à parl
de la rencontre de la de l'événement qui
l'a construit l'événement marquant de sa
vie qui a fait qu'à un moment donné il a
même changé de vie qu'est-ce qui qui
était le plus marquant pour vous moi ce
qui m'a complètement changé ma vie en
tout cas c'est ce qui a complètement
changé ma vie c'est c'est la musique
d'ailleurs sur le reportage la chanson
qu'on entend à la fin c'est la chanson
que que vous avez écrite et qui a été
interprétée par Barbara c'est une
chanson j'avais eu mon accident de moto
et puis je je savais pas ce que ce que
j'allais devenir si j'allais être encore
vivant ou pas et puis bon juste j'ai
écrit cette chanson parce que c'était la
une chanson pour une femme que j'aimais
et qui résumait à peu près à peu près
tout tout ce que je faisais dans ma vie
amoureuse et puis c'est cette chanson
Mon père sur à l'hôpital est tombé
dessus et puis a appelé Barbara et lui
disant en lui disant qu'il j'avais écrit
un beau texte et elle lui a lu et puis
elle a tout de suite voulu chanter cette
chanson donc je lui ai donné et elle a
chanté sur son dernier album voilà c'est
la seule que j'ai signé en fait de mon
nom le titre est signifiant de chans ou
à force de oui en fait à force de mêtre
chercher c'est toi que j'ai
perdu tout en signant pour la première
fois de votre nom oui don Marc Olivier
qu'est-ce qui d'après vous est le plus
le plus marquant dans dans la vie de
Guillaume moi je pense ça rejo un peu le
le titre du livre mais l'amour en fait
quand il dit tout donné c'est pas tout
livré c'est c'est aimer et Guillaume je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui aime et
qui a de temps en temps du mal à le dire
ouais euh peut-être de temps en temps à
son père c'estàdire que et c'est sa
façon de le dire et ce qu'il a construit
c'est l'amour il me semble et et une
question qui va sembler anodine par
rapport à tout ce que vous avez dit mais
qu'est-ce que vous attendez maintenant
de quand même de votre Père qui est
présent tout au long du tout au long du
livre que du bonheur je lui souhaite moi
et qu'est-ce qu'il vous a dit après
avoir lu ce livre rien rien il m'a il
m'en a pas parlé il m'en a pas parl
peut-être pas directement mais tu sais
très bien ce qu'il a pensé de ce que tu
disais à guillum non je sais pas si si
si ah oui enfin bon il ouais il m'a dit
il m'a dit qu'il trouvait ça bon un peu
impudique non mais c'est pas la même
manière MRE alors moi je lis pas gala
moi mais je te l'ai l ils sont bien
qu'est-ce qui c'est quoi le côté positif
je répond au
téléphone guum c'est son côté peut-être
pudique qui l'empêche de le raconter
mais moi j'ai lu gala qui et le monde
qui reprenait gala pour te le lire et
Gérard de pardieu que je connais pas
était particulièrement sensible à la
façon dont s'exprime Guillaume
reconnaissait un certain nombre
peut-être de d'erreurs et était surtout
content que Guillaume puisse exprimer
des choses et il lui en voulait pas une
seconde il comprenait très bien une
forme de souffrance et il la respectait
et et il faisait un pas vers lui quoi et
je continue non si et Guillaume ait et
Guillaume était particulièrement
sensible au pas qu'il faisait vers lui
oui mais il serait bien mais c'est
toujours par média interposé enfin bon
aiade M interpos Marco veut veut
positiver la chose c'est pas c'est la
réalité je suis assez curieux de voir
que guaume le sa très bien ça l'a
particulièrement touché mais en revanche
il vous le dira pas donc je préfère le
dire à sa place voilà mais dans ce que
j'entends moi c'est Guillaume Guillaume
vous attendiez quelque chose qui soit en
direct avec vous à la limite moi
j'attendais rien du
tout direct c'est direct voilà oui oui
oui mais même il a une musique de
silence que je trouve assez intéressante
en tout cas que je connais très bien
donc Gérard donc ça va très bien je suis
pas du tout ni surpris positivement ni
négativement ça me ça ne me dérange pas
donc moi je pr
dire
che peut-être oui on va changer les
partitions alors c'est un peu tard bah
c'est-à-d que c'est sans arrêt partagé
entre le il y a marqué haine amour dans
dans le livre au ça c'est des gens voyez
pas même mon père c'est une personne à
part entière donc mais mais c'est vrai
que c'est même mon père c'est une
personne
à ce monstre sacré mais c'est c'est quel
c'est tout enveloppe corporelle c'est
c'est déjà un filtre au sentiment c'est
pour moi c'est vrai que c'est le
sentiment d'abord et donc c'est pour ça
que je vous ai dit qu'est-ce qui m'a
construit qu'est-ce qui a changé ma vie
c'est la musique parce que là il y a pas
de personne il y a pas de de nom il y a
pas d'identité il y a pas de il y a pas
d'usurpateur il y a pas de il y a pas de
filtre c'est vraiment ce sentiment là
c'est la musique l'harmonie c'est ça
vraiment qui qui m'a qui m'a construit
et là vous êtes complètement en dehors
d'ailleurs de la sphère de votre père
parce que moi ce qui m'a frappé tout au
long de de ce livre c'est le sentiment
de légitimité ou d'illégitimité he tout
au long du livre ça revi avec avec une
phrase moi moi alors qui m'a vraiment
stupéfaite c'était l'une des questions
de de Marc Olivier qui vous demande
pourquoi vous fuyez le bonheur vous
dites pour ne pas dépasser mon père pour
le laisser là où il est en haut h
c'est moi ça m'a ça m'a sidéré cette
phrase
ouais quoi ouais non mais c'est c'est ça
ça je pense que c'est un réflexe
d'enfant ouais oui mais maintenant
vousêes justement un petit garçon ou oui
mais je sais mais c'est peut-être pour
ça que maintenant je me dis mais j'ai du
bonheur j'ai des moments de bonheur et
puis c'est vrai que par rapport à cette
histoire de légitimité je pense que j'ai
le droit aussi à au bonheur mais c'est
vrai que pendant très longtemps je me
suis interdit de je me suis interdit
ouis le bonheur mais est-ce que vous
pensez que vous le laisserit toujours en
haut ou qu'à un moment donné vous pouvez
on a le droit on a le droit de dépasser
le père c'est vous avez raison que c'est
les enfants on a le droit de tuer le
père le dépasser d'AV mais comme moi je
le faisais dans l'ombre si vous voulez
dans la musique et moi je le savais
j'étais seul le savoir et bon mon Alice
me dit que c'est pas
suffisant alors donc oui peut-être que
je vais assumer finalement autre chose
mais faut faut me laisser un peu de
temps encore ah mais là vous êtes vous
êtes en chemin oui je suis en chemin là
comment on devient père à son tour quand
on a quand on a des difficultés aussi à
déjà à être le fils d'e et comment on
devient le père ça ça seit très
naturellement si on si on est on n pas
trop débile mais mais le côté des
agréable et en même temps répétitif
finalement qui pourrait qui pourrait
faire que j'ai beaucoup d'intelligence
pour ma propre éducation celle qu'on m'a
donné c'est qu'au bout d'un moment il y
en a juste cette réponse après avoir
épuisé toutes les autres et bien ma
chérie parce que c'est comme
ça on la connait tous voilà je pense que
là c'est on est tous on est tous pareil
là-dessus parce que on a épuisé toutes
les réponses les machin oui tu comprends
le lait se mélange un peu plus un peu
moins c'est tiède mais pas vraiment
chaud bah parce que c'est comme ça on
arrive toujours à ce moment-là Marc
Olivier on a le sentiment que que
Guillaume comme
ça dit tout sur ce qu'il vit la vie et
tout mais moi je sens une énorme dans le
fond c'est une énorme
pudur c'est paradoxalement je trouve
c'est l'une des personnes les plus
pudiques qu' dans il est paradoxal
Guillaume je pense que le livre il
aurait pu s'appeler paradoxe parce que
c'est il est paradoxal Guillaume il peut
être extrêmement calme comme extrêmement
peut-être pas violent mais agité ouais
violent ouis complètement calme ou
complètement distroy l'épisode dernier
épisode dont on a beaucoup parler
l'amputation de la jambe Guillaume
est-ce que cette amputation ça a
transformé votre vie est-ce que ça fait
partie des des choses les plus les plus
difficiles ça m'a rendu encore plus
vivant encore plus respectueux de de
certaines choses et de la vie en général
et de et de comment être doux avec ça en
particulier et de de de protéger au
maximum des les gens que j'aime et même
ceux que j'aime pas des fois bon mais
c'est c'est triste à dire mais ça m'a ça
m'a eu humanisé au dernier degré
et et ça m'a donné beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de force ça vous a
vraiment transformé ouis ben oui parce
que du coup j'ai quand même arrêté tout
ce qui me toutes les fuites que je
pouvais avoir que ce soit dans l'alcool
ou même je regardais encore dans les les
résumés d'émissions où j'étais c'est
c'est pas que j'ai changé mais ça m'a
fait fait évoluer à une vitesse énorme
je suis passé dans une autre dimension
c'est-à-dire que j'aurais peut-être pas
pu accéder à cette dimension là sans
sans y passer 20 30 ans peut-être de
sagesse et de d'épreuves encore et
toujours les mêmes et les répétitions
non là j'ai j'ai eu un vieillissement
accéléré qui m'a pas enlevé ma jeunesse
mais m et ça t'as peut-être donné tu me
dis si je dis une bêtise un peu de
compassion enfin envers toi-même
peut-être visàis de moi-même ou j'en
avais beaucoup pour les autres mais je
peux le dire
peux dire c'est vrai on en vient à ce
ouais un pe peut-être peut-être un peuou
c'est plus un peu plus car enfin je fais
plus attention à moi ou oui en quoi vous
êtes retrouvé vous dans dans Guillaume
qu'est-ce qui vous intéressait euh une
forme de souffrance et euh sa souffrance
m'a renvoyé finalement à la mienne qui
est peut-être moins apparente voilà mais
quelle souffrance non mais
sur Non mais sur quelle sur quelle
souffrance non mais sur quelle
souffrance on a pas partagé la même
chose
mais rien à voir mais avec des
apparences finalement très
très trompeuse et très on est finalement
très différent Guillaume dans le livre
il dit que j'ai un langage de banquier
lui un langage d'artiste donc on se
renvoie la balle comme ça parce que j'ai
peut-être un peu un côté un peu brutal
et protéger aussi il fait comme ça mais
je pense qu'il a une la même sensibilité
enà on va le dire autrement plutôt que
la souffrance peut-être la sensibilité
comme ça ser com bien parce que vous il
y a pas de parcours de drogue ni de
prison non mais je l'explique pour que
c'est une souff a pas de vie caché ça
serait pas un tabou
d'ailleursab ça ser pas du tout tabou
mais c'est pas le cas mais disons que
peut-être qu'avec une apparence un peu
trompeuse de quelqu'un peut-être qui
donne l'impression d'être extrêmement
sûr de soi et d'être de temps en temps
peut-être arrogant en fait je me
retrouve chez Guillaume dans une forme
de
fragilité peut-être ou de ouais de de
quelqu'un qui est peut-être moins fort
d'apparence quoi Marc Olivier quand même
une question personnelle parce que vous
êtes là côte à côte c'est bien c'est
bien beau d'avoir interview et Guillaume
et vous alors une rencontre qui a
bouleversé votre s oui quand mêmeand Mme
sû je l'attendais questionand mêmeme
c'est forcément une rencontre amoureuse
qui a transformé ma vie mais depuis
longtemps forcément une rencontre
amoureuse pourquoi forcément la
rencontre amoureuse bah parce que
forcément on se construit par rapport à
ça enfin moi en tout cas ouais et
Guillaume on peut penser bientôt ne plus
du tout entendre parler de vous dans les
dans les médias et que vous soyez en
train de travailler juste sur la musique
et mais de toute façon c'est ce que je
fais en permanence moi mais mais c'est
non là au contraire là je je vais enfin
faire un coming out donc si je vais
faire la musique mais devant tout le
monde l'idée c'est de signer sa musique
et enfin de signer en gros Guillaume de
pardieu c'est ça j'is pensé à plusieurs
pseud oh ben alors ça n'aura servi à
rien votre livre franchement faire tout
ce
livre tout dire tout donner pour arriver
à de plus signer de son nom franchement
de par Dieu il fera
j'ai toujours signé Guillaume en fait
donc pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
Inna Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche